Hi was pile the top of the head often ornamented with jewels or trinkets.
Her face was always made up and she wore the finest gowns and jewelry.
I was only 19 years old.
She was already a queen and then the tumultuous times in which she lived,
she soon became a symbol of all that was wrong with French royalty.
So in the video today,
let's explore the life of Mariam's.
When asked the woman who was the face of rail access during the French
revolution
then now inextricably linked with France and so on.
It wasn't a native of the country,
descended from the Habsburg line as she was born into royalty in Austria.
Marie Antoinette's entered the world in 1755 she was the daughter of the empress
of Austria and the holy Roman emperor like many born into royalty,
she had a lengthly name,
Maria Antonia Josepha.
Joanna growing up,
she was educated by private tutors,
are education focused on morality and religion.
This was typical at the time for an aristocratic females education,
though she had a private tutor that works with her aunts when I was new,
great shakes at academics.
In fact,
she could barely read and write her native German,
much less the French that she also had to study.
As one of her tutors described.
She is rather lazy and extremely frivolous.
She is hard to teach on swing as agree off during the seven years' war.
She was only eight years old when it's ended,
but the outcome of the conflict quite seriously effected how future you see.
As the empress of Austria,
I was going to its mother where's the political leader at the end of the seven
years war,
it was in her best interest to keep an alliance between the French and the
Austrians ends in the 18th century.
The best way to forge an alliance was three marriage,
two years after the war ended when Antoinette,
who is but 10 years old,
her mother pegs the 11 year old ads to the French crown was at best about for a
son in law.
The necessary arrangements were amazing.
Does the age of only 14 Antoinette was married off into foreign royalty to Louie
or Gusta ball ball.
Marie Antoinette's entry into France as a teenager.
It was a spectacular affair.
A caravan was made up of nearly 60 carriage is accompanied by 117 footmen ends
at 376 horses.
The destination for this variable parade was a royal retreat in the forest
outside of Paris,
but they had to make a stop as they approached the border with France.
Antoinette had to be dressed to look the part of French royalty.
I was pal does,
her makeup was done,
and she puts on a dress that matched the lavish expectations of the French
court.
When they arrived,
Antoinette's showed herself to be just a teenager.
She was impulsive ends,
unable to control her excitement about being in a new place,
about some meters,
seemed to be husbands rushing out of the carriage.
She dashed up to the King of France and when she curtsied,
he was charms,
but the king's grandson.
The future events,
when ads did not share his birth through extroverted personality,
he did not die shop to her around her arrival.
Instead,
he aversion desires gave her a quick formal kiss on the cheek and then stage
silence.
Meanwhile,
[inaudible] and the king chattered away merrily one day off to Antoinette's as
mess.
Louie the t were married the May the 16th 1770 wedding ceremony.
It was held in the chapel of the famed palace of Versailles and it's when it's
addressed was white and silver opulence gown dax out in diamonds,
but there was a major problem with the gown that it wasn't the right size for
any bride.
Discovering on your wedding day that your dress doesn't fit well,
it would be a nightmare,
but imagine being the future queen with all eyes of the court and the country
upon you.
She didn't refresh,
however,
at least not publicly.
She was expected to walk down the aisle and take the hands of Louis Bull on in
marriage,
so that's what she did with our chef showing through the back of her dress in
between rows of stone diamonds.
The ceremony itself was a long mass and the grievant huddle on a dower
expression for the entire time.
Then when it came to seal the contract with the signatures of the bride and
groom Antwon as drip to ink on the signature,
obscuring the name.
Doing so was considered bad luck for the marriage and things.
While they didn't get any better,
as the day went on,
it was traditional in this era of a newlyweds to be followed to their bed
chamber by a crowd.
In the case of Amazon,
as in Louie,
the crown's included royal dignitaries and an arch Bishop,
the bishop gave the blessing and the crown dismissed as the couple disappeared
behind drawn curtains and they undressed,
but as it would seem the entirety of Europe and the next day they didn't
actually consummate the marriage as was expected of newlyweds and indeed for the
next seven years.
They didn't consummate the marriage.
To this day,
there's never been a clear answer to why it took so long for the two to fulfill
this marital obligation.
Historians have put forward theories to of those popular theories are that Louie
had phimosis they condition the men.
Sex was painful for him or it's simply that the two teenagers were just young
and it's confused,
but it did seem that the whole world knew about the lack of intimacy between the
young royals and cleaning Antoinette's.
Mother and [inaudible] mother regularly corresponded via letter and their
discussions offer a glimpse into Antoinette's early years in the French court
and these reveals that she was very homesick.
Madame,
my very dear mother,
I have not received one of your dear letters without having the tears come to my
eyes and she disliked to the French customer royalty being attended to always.
I preserve my rouge and wash my hands in front of the whole world.
She complained to her mother in a letter I love that spent time in her letters
admonishing her daughter for her frivolous behavior at court as well as for not
performing and Marisol obligations.
In one letter she told Angela ads there's,
in order to be a good wife,
she needed to to lavish more caresses on Louis.
Part of the problem might have been there.
Different schedules and lifestyles,
big married.
They lived two very different lives and so when as was,
as are going and just social as ever,
there's a husband's remained quiet,
avoiding the frivolities of course life that his wife so enjoyed the differences
they graded on the marriage.
And so when that wrote to her friends,
my tastes are not the same as the kings who is only interested in hunting and
his metal working.
He would often go to bed well before midnight while she was just getting started
with her parties late into the night.
Then she'd wake up late morning after I'd already been up attending to his
duties or studies from an early hour.
Eventually bans when it's brother were sent to France to talk to Louie.
It's not clear what ends when his brother said to Louie,
but after that chat the couple was finally able to consummate their marriage.
By the time of their marriage was consummated,
Louis' father had died and the two had been king and queen for three years and
at this point she was just 21 years old
as Queen Antoinette's tastes remains lavish much.
Do you have mother's dismay and it almost pretentious letter her mother rose,
you lead a dissipated life.
I hope I shall not live to see if he disaster that is likely to ensue.
A hair itself was saying,
mark,
if our opulence with wigs and ornamentation piled feet at all of the heads,
I was silly,
extravagantly done that she could even honey to tiny visas of water in this.
Do you keep the ornamental flowers fresh?
Leonard Audi,
a hairdresser became a cultural icon in his own right.
The women of the courts and of high society in Paris began emulating
Antoinette's hairstyles.
With morning women.
Even going so far as do ornaments,
their towers of hair with earns her jewelry was also flashy to have a diamond
bracelet.
It's well worth as much as an entire mansion in Paris just getting dressed in
the morning.
Was it literally a production?
One of Ann's when it's maids,
would hold up a book of fabric samples for her to help her decide what to wear.
Then she'd put on layers of undergarments,
including a frame.
If I'm the has scars it to emphasize her hips,
of course,
it of course.
Then layers of fabric and then her dress again.
Mother did predictably and not approve.
As you know,
I've always been of the opinion that fashion should be followed in moderation
but should never be taken to extremes.
A beautiful young woman,
a graceful queen,
has no need for such madness.
On the contrary,
simplicity of dress is more of a fitting and it's more worthy of a queen.
I love my little queen and watch everything you do and feel.
I must not hesitate to draw your attention to this little frivolity.
The royal couple was living well and to showing it off,
but the people of France weren't sharing and the opulence and it's not all of
the French population,
was impressed with their new queens luxurious style in the late 1770s the
harvest in France,
it wasn't going well.
Green was it a premium prices were skyrocketing and farmers and peasants,
they were hurting.
They were literally riots in the street over Brett.
It is during these rights.
That answer now is we're supposed to have said let them eat cake,
but you never actually said this.
That phrase was attributed to her much later in 1843 aunts when has may have
never uttered that famously callous phrase,
but she certainly wasn't sympathetic to the plights of the peasants.
In fact,
even as as subjects with suffering,
she continued spending even more.
She gambled down.
She spent money to construct her own private retreat at the building known as
the trine on already existed.
That's when I though she needed to make it her own.
She installed artificial rivers,
the Rotunda and a series of what appeared to be in rustic cottages.
Once inside it became clear they weren't anything but they were furnished in the
typically comfortable style of the wealthy,
complete with pool tables,
silk hangings,
and other ornate wall Waldeck or fine China in luxury furniture broads the cost
of the retreat to an astounding 2 million francs beyond the cost of the decker
and the property.
The triathlon also caused other problems for Antoinette's among her subjects.
People wondered why a Queen would need such a retreat,
so they jumped to conclusions and began spreading rumors and gossip.
The Queen,
she was hosting men.
They said,
I've seen gatherings that to be happening at the Trianon.
Why else would she need a lavish getaway for just herself and to have friends?
One rema,
it persisted and that was a vans.
When it's a fan with the Swedish diplomat axle to fasten it in 2016 a team of
researches announced their Dakota.
The latter that showed Antwon ads and the person's relationship went beyond just
discussing matters of state among Vindico did passages is this,
I will end this letter.
There's knots without telling you my dear and gentle friends that I love you
madly and that there is never a moment in which I do not adore you.
The two that first been introduced in 1774 and saw each other more and more as
fascinating,
did more events at the French course.
You'd have to Europe for a time to find in the American revolution,
but that didn't,
didn't the feelings between him then Antwon apps,
another letter that survived the centuries has first and telling his sister that
he could never marry because there's one true love was already taken.
The Queen,
I'll shoot.
We're certainly giving the people of France a great deal to talk about
discussions of Antwon out as eight traitors and our husbands and about half
frivolity with money.
We're spreading pamphlets distributed throughout France drawings an answer and
as a company to set up words,
shoving her in extravagant dresses.
This very great ire towards her and the rest of the royal family
as the king and queen were acting as if nothing was different about life.
The people of France,
we're getting angrier band Sangria.
In 1789 king Louie had sent troops to a science.
Paris and French citizens were starting to worry it might be a move to dissolve
the National Assembly.
In response,
900 Frenchmen descended upon Paris and stormed the Bastille prison.
They stole weapons and ammunition,
but the events was much more than the stockpiling of weapons.
It was a symbol of the people being ready to take on the powerful forces of the
monarchy.
The Bastille was a fortress,
but it was also the prison weapon.
Critical enemies were kept.
It was a symbol of the Monica use power.
And by taking it over,
the people showed just how weak the monarchy could be.
The storming of the Bastille on July the 14 to 1789 is widely considered to be
the start of the French revolution and things were moving pretty fast.
By October,
the crowds of revolutionaries and grown to thousands,
10,000 French has gathered outside the PSI calling for the king and his queen to
be dragged to Paris among them thousands of women who had marched miles from
Paris.
And along the way they were joined by men with guns.
When they showed up outside the royal residents,
Lee,
we didn't know what to do.
His first instinct was to escape,
so we ordered his carriage is be prepared.
They were no match for the angry crowds.
The carriage were ruins and to Louis and just family remains trapped in the
palace stay when much safer in selling though some of the crowds trying to get
it down to an ads and they nearly succeeded to garbs were killed as the crowd
forced their way towards our quarters and so on.
As it wasn't in the bedroom,
though she had left the air and was safe in the dining rooms of Louise
quarter's.
Soon after troops under the commands of Marquis de Lafayette arrived and were
able to restore order.
The piece was not to last though the crowds were able to capture the king and
queen and forced them back to Paris in a procession led by the heads of their
dead body guards,
which were hoisted up on Pike's throughout the crisis Antwon when ash was
meeting with ambassadors and writing letters to other European officials calling
on them to help out the French monarchy that we meanwhile seems it's a loss for
how to help.
Then in 1891 aided by the help of her lover to Ferguson and not Louis and swing
that's put together plans and get the royal family out of France and away from
the danger of an angry at public.
The plan was to escape to the Netherlands where they could plot a counter
revolution.
Amazon has proved herself able to make decisions and plan,
but when it came time for her to escape,
her desire for luxury got in the way.
Again,
a French general had told the royals that their journey would be much safer if
they made it in to small and conspicuous carriages.
Instead,
Antoinette's demanded that they use larger carriages that could be outfitted
with a full silver dinner service as well as a wine chest.
Also joining the royal family in their luxurious carriage was to [inaudible] the
plan called for him to leave the royal family a short way into the journey,
then meets back up with them at their destination.
He wants it to to travel the whole way as part of their group to offer
protection,
but Louie demanded you follow the plan and separate from the group.
Shortly after the person's departure from the group,
they ran into trouble.
A peasant's recognize the king and was able to muster up the crowds to attack
for carriage.
They weren't dragged into a house and held captive.
Eventually they were allowed to return to Paris,
but still held captive.
The French assembly allowed Louie to serve as king,
but he didn't really have any power and downs.
When asked,
well,
she wasn't much in favor of the assembly at all.
She was actively working against them,
writing to officials throughout Europe about how terrible she thought the new
constitution was.
She was also pretty clear in how she felt about the members of the assembly
themselves,
describing them as a heap of black guards,
madmen and beasts.
During this time,
Larry heard also declared war on Austria,
things they were falling apart all around aunts when asked and they were about
to get a whole lot worse.
In 1792 the French royal family was forced into the Medieval Temple Tower,
fortress as they were held prisoner,
the millennium old Monica,
you're France was dissolved and a new French republic took its place as all this
was going on outside.
The royal family tried to live a somewhat normal life in prison that we in
Murray tutor their children chess and played instruments,
but they will also trying to bring them the backs of power and there was this
effort that ultimately undid her and Louie the couple that hit in the letters
they received from foreign powers in a box inside the prison.
When the correspondence was discovered,
Louie was dragged on trial.
He was ultimately sentenced to death with the revolutionary leader roles,
p APP or claiming Louie must die so that the country may live on [inaudible] and
the children were able to spend a few final hours with him before he met his
fate at the Guillotine with 20,000 Frenchmen looking on months later,
that's when I had herself would be the one on the platform.
After Louise Execution,
she was brought to a new prison,
a prison with the dire nickname of death,
Santa's chamber here.
Ray sympathetic military officer actually attempted to help her escape when his
efforts were uncovered bands,
when ash was put on trial right away in order to avoid any danger of her
escaping,
she was charged with treason and theft and it was left up to a male jury to
decide her face.
It only took two days for them to decide that she was guilty and she should be
sentenced to death.
The 37 year old queen made one final trip through the streets of Paris.
Oh,
how Sean?
In preparation for execution,
she sat stoically in a carriage on the ride to the guillotine platform where she
would ultimately meet her face.
When she arrived at the platform,
the priests told her to have courage.
How response?
Courage.
I've shown it for years.
Thank you.
I shall lose it at the moments when my sufferings are to and from the moment she
was born,
Marie Antoinette was destined to play a role on the world stage.
How mother set her up for a powerful marriage and marriage that thrust her into
the midst of the French revolution,
and it's made her the ultimate representation of the excesses of royalty.
She was only alive for 37 years,
but in that time,
she suddenly left her mark on the world.
So I really hope you enjoyed the video.
If you did,
please hit that thumbs up button below and do not forget to subscribe.
Also,
we've got a new feature.
If you would like to vote on who we do here at biographics,
you can visit our companion site.
It's called biographics.org and click on the bio,
vote in the bar at the top,
and then you'll be able to suggest people and also vote on existing suggestions.
So go check that out.
And as always,
thank you for watching.
Okay.